ah remember the good old days where we
could follow every anime being released
I don't you thought you didn't have
enough time to follow full 2022 anime
well introducing winter 2023 what we've
added an extra 12 shows on top of how
many four had that's an extra full
season of anime per week we've got a
whole 54 new anime this season so I'm
sure we've got some quality stuff right
let's see we got more isekai a lot of
isakai spy extreme daddy ghost dust over
Man's Best Friend near automata okay now
we're talking Nia has one of the most
hard-hitting stories in the history of
video games an incredible profound
introspective tale exploring philosophy
Consciousness that will make you
question the meaning of life itself
let's see how near fans are appreciating
this incredible story this [__] video
is so cool it looks like he's actually
in a video game I grew up playing uh
Dave Mirra bikes and this looks exactly
like the game did and it's saying he
managed to like sync it up so perfectly
and it just I don't know how how she
like the accuracy of the it's it's
perfect
[Music]
what's your favorite pop tart obviously
it's the strawberry one but there's such
a basic [__] [__] answer all right
you want a real answer joey yes the 2002
tie-in merch Pop-Tarts that came out for
the Spider-Man movie
change you know sometimes all you need
in the show some dumb bloody fun and
this show about a group of portrayed
Samurai taking revenge on their
revengees called Revengers seems to be
exactly that again the butcher urobuchi
is back baby we got the blood we got the
action we got the violence we don't got
Tokyo in the name that's probably why
more people aren't watching this if you
like your anime with a splice and
revenge on the side just look at how
hard this guy gets revenged revenge
God damn that guy did some revenge in
there's a lot of anime to get through
this season I don't want a browser that
gives me the optimal anime viewing
experience which is why today's sponsor
is Opera GX are you a true gamer don't
answer that then Opera GX is the only
web browser you should be using what's a
gamer's Worst Enemy No not gotcha lag
and choppy frame rates and gotcha GX
control lets you enhance your gameplay's
performance on PC while your browser is
still open and gets rid of lag caused by
Gaming while listening to music it's
perfect when you're a filthy tab holder
like me and wants to keep a bunch of
tabs open without your browser hurting
your gaming performance not only that
but you could say goodbye to the plain
looking browsers you're used to for all
you dark mode lovers the Accents in
Opera GX are inspired by Neon Lights and
how they break the darkness of the
Knight but if you're degenerate like me
and prefer the light you can still
choose from many different special
themes wallpapers and colors not enough
you Gamers just click the little
controller icon in the top left corner
to go to the GX Corner which keeps you
up to date with all the latest and
greatest in free gaming the best deals
new releases and breaking gaming news
and would you look at that if you use
the link in the description the GX
Corner comes with an exclusive feature
that lets you see all the latest videos
from the anime Zone himself so what are
you waiting for use the link in the
description to download the Opera GX
browser for absolutely free thank you
very much to Opera GX for sponsoring us
today and back to the video
[Music]
at this point I'm just convinced some
isakaya AI generated because there is no
way The Reincarnation of the strongest
Exorcist in another world isn't a title
written by chat GPT black hair
overpowered protag a harem that [__]
scene where they go to magic school and
everyone surprised the main character
Can Do Magic without any incantation
this has it all or wait are we missing
something
[Music]
and there it is God have a good Easter
guy without a bit of slavery it's just
why is this a Trope when did this become
a staple of visakai anime I swear to God
if I see one more anime with slavery
slavery now this is the good [__]
villain Saga is back with Studio map at
this time on their way to collecting
every single anime franchise to ever
exist they seem to be doing an excellent
job taking them out from Studio wits
once again this looks like it's truly
gonna do justice to the legendary Source
material stardew Valley all right we
also got
[__] how many more sequels do we have
here Tokyo Revengers 2 nagatoro's second
attack bungo stray dogs 4 rising of The
Shield Lolly 2 inspector 2 danmachi 4. I
think there are more sequels in this one
season than all the anime in some older
Seasons but all that doesn't matter
because anos the Giga chart vaulty goat
has returned to take his crown once more
oh I don't know he doesn't seem that
different from every Easter protagonist
oh I'm sorry how many other anime
protagonists you know that's won a war
had his first kiss killed a guy with a
heartbeat got his own Harem is the
strongest in the world had 10 000 kids
when he was one month old well looks
like we got some fairy slaves this time
gentlemen
are we not
do we not all agree slavery is bad
will have no fear I shall put a stop to
this endless cycle of slavery
with more slavery well it looks like we
got ourselves a cute little Shojo about
a girl and a sleigh I mean worker fairy
that's what I called in the show that's
totally different she's innocent just
look at her innocently buying this fairy
in a market that traffic's fairies such
a bargain I'm proper nice as well once
he though that aside it's good to see
more Shojo anime coming on now and this
looks gorgeous I'm loving the watercolor
style background and character designs
if you're one of the many OG starved
Shoujo fans in a modern day this might
be one for you
foreign
arrested on suspicion of Murder My Bros
it's starting the era of tomboys is upon
us short hair check cute fangs check
muscles check neuron activation double
check if any man here wishes to join our
church of tomboys today you need just
utter the holy phrase love the kind of
woman that can kick my ass girls if you
think the worst thing he can say is no
we got tomachan is a girl a tomboy so
friendly so completely overpowering she
gets bro zoned this looks pretty cute
actually you could have just said this
was tomboy nazakikun and that's all you
needed to say baby
we got assassination classroom except
the girls try to become spies in an
organization based entirely around cute
anime girls I like to call this
aesthetic wait this isn't a gacha game
adaptation you know after licorice
recall I'm getting a bit concerned now
about just how many nations have decided
to put their entire National Security on
the back of adorable anime girls when
kagio summer first aired it asked the
question what happens if two Cinder Rays
like each other but now the ice guy in
his cool female collie asks what happens
if two kudarays like each other and I
think I have the answer black holes with
the mass of our sun will take 10 000
billion billion billion billion billion
billion years to evaporate nor Point
North North one percent of its mass
meaning black holes will be around for
more years after the last star has died
then there are atoms in the observable
universe they will be the oldest thing
left in the dying universe only second
to these two getting a step closer to
confessing
[Music]
on the hype train we have buddy daddy
showing what would happen if John Wick
had to bring your daughter to work day
this is kind of like spikes family
except Anya's parents aren't casually
bringing her along while they murder
groups of people or assassinating her
biological dad right in front of her
this is a family-friendly show right
ignoring this four-year-old's incoming
repressed trauma this one's pretty cute
actually and a lot of that is down to
how good of a job they're doing at
portraying this kid
I think they did an even better job than
Anya making her feel like a kid forget
your perfectly crafted birth rate fixing
anime daughters this is the real deal
because sometimes she's just an annoying
little [__] ain't she
I want to apologize well this is one I
was most excited about try gun Stampede
if you got into anime in the same
generation I did Trigun was probably one
of the first anime you watch so I
couldn't be more excited to see this
reimagining from Studio orange you got a
Sci-Fi desert setting of Dune meets
Clint Eastwood some good old-fashioned
spaghetti western action Vash is just as
goofy and charismatic as ever for all
the radical changes they've made
compared to the originals I've enjoyed
the first few episodes immensely now
let's talk about 3D once again Studio
orange is proving why they are the king
of 3D anime you can say you don't dig
the style but you can't say that this is
a badly animated show the insane Dynamic
action shots the character animations
and little micro Expressions they have
nothing feels rigid or stiff for a 3D
show this looks more expressive than
most 2D anime on a purely visual front
studio orange have upped their game once
again continuing to break all
preconceptions about CGI anime my only
concern is if this star will be able to
capture the darker sides of the story if
it is even a remotely following what
came before Oh I recognize that City
from anywhere this is a fantasy anime
let's see what's going on in this
fantasy world
[Applause]
[Music]
we got a group of fantasy Misfits that
have been thrown out of their original
groups to band together to create an
outcast group and I don't know why I
find this so amusing but the main
protagonist's name is Nick yes Nick
I don't know why I find that so funny
and here we have the whole the whole
theme of the most iconic anime
characters of all time Goku
saitama [__] Nick in it if you ever
think you're failing in Romance in life
remember this guy just like the
prettiest girl in class who shows up at
his door cleans his room takes care of
him and Cooks in the perfect meals every
day and all he had to do was
give her an umbrella
that's it it should have been me not
that was just a joke though see that's
not me I'm in a happy
trip and this is way too pure and
wholesome for my tastes just look at how
innocently she takes care of him and
cooks for him and cleans for him
disgusting this relationship is so
wholesome no guy would ever want that in
their own lives okay Cindy you can put
the gun away now oh here we go another
show in the teasing genre now we're
talking that last show is way too pure
I've seen enough nagatora to know where
this is going
wait a minute this is just more
wholesome is there absolutely no horny
this season come on it must be somewhere
oh boy it's time for the era of to be
horniness to enter the anime Community
Nero Tom says one of the most beloved
action jrpgs of modern time so a lot of
fans will be watching this closely with
judging eyes and so far it's pretty good
the action looks decent they are doing
my gal to be Justice in every Department
the CG even looks really good for a PS2
game it seems like this is on course for
a decent adaptation so far but but Nia
has one of the most profound and amazing
video game experiences of all time but
part of the reason it works is because
the Creator is a [__] madman so much
of nears insane experience is tied to
the crazy way yokotaro decided to
integrate it into the gameplay you
complete the game he forces you to
replay it not once but twice to get the
full story it has 26 possible endings
some of the chennineers even out there
for a lot of Gamers so I'm not sure how
well the near automata experience can be
translated to a TV series but either way
I'll be very curious to see how they
continue need to adopt oh
oh this must be the secret anime
original ending two years ago Studio
binds blasted onto the scene with
mushoka tensei and this season they are
back with oshimai which is unironically
and perhaps a bit worryingly one of the
best animated shows this season I'll be
honest I've heard from Margaritas this
is meant to be an innocent wholesome
show but there is some sassy wassy anime
[__] going on in the background here
because at the end of the day it's about
an unemployed degenerate man who wakes
up one day to find himself as a cute
young anime girl yes that's right
they've made a story about a Discord
more turning into his own profile
picture
me not him the creator of kakiguri is
back and they just can't seem to get
away from the casino setting can they my
man's out here casually getting a royal
flush which has a no point no no no one
five four percent chance of happening or
as a gacha game we would call it rather
good odds this looks like a Dopey fun
action Series where everyone has a
different [__] power depending on
whatever playing card they have you got
this girl who has the power of Thai food
then Americans be like
looking like it could be a lot of fun
but I think more people will be watching
it if they just went ahead and called
this card Captain JoJo alright where's
all these guys this season someone say
he's a guy I think this is a normal
fantasy
finally a fantasy anime that goes we
don't need to copy every other fantasy
Easter guy world to ever be made
let's copy Attack on Titan instead I kid
I care this is more Monster Hunter than
it is Attack on Titan I'm always excited
to see promising anime original projects
and this one is yet to fully show his
cards so I'm definitely going to be
keeping a close eye on this if not only
to keep track of how they handle the
relationship between the main Duo of
this older guy and the younger looking
teenage girl
oh an onion
um
bye [__]
no he is an easy guy concept I can get
behind what's the best way to save up
for early retirement just embezzle your
money to another world you know we've
had enough morally correct power fantasy
protagonists I'm glad there's finally a
girl who's showing us what isakai was
always meant to be about escaping the
IRS holy Jesus how many more isakara
fantasy shows do we have this season
we've got a natural farming isekai this
time where they do real farming instead
of killing dragons with carrots or
whatever the hell this is I know you
think you've seen every ridiculous
isakai power up imaginable but campfire
cooking in another world with my absurd
skill has introduced possibly the most
overpowered ability in isekai
protagonist has ever acquired Amazon
Prime chilling in my 30s after getting
fired from the Demon King's Army finally
an easy Sky protagonist with a worthless
power I can relate to being 30.
there's yet another fantasy about an
entomo game villainous to his credit
this one has a pretty unique premise
instead of a girl getting Issa card into
an atomic game the in-game characters
can actually hear their Players let's
play commentary as the voice of God we
finally got lock picking lawyer in
another world dude gets easy card just
to find himself opening chess for his
party reborn to the master of Blade from
hero King to extraordinary Squire looks
alright actually it's always refreshing
to see dragons that not only on CG but
looks good I can say that about the rest
of the show as well it looks way better
than it has any right to be but with so
many isakai and fantasy shows airing the
season I might actually have to be
selective with which shows I watch which
is why I've had to put all my chips into
one isakai pick this season it would
probably be this the magical revolution
of the reincarnated princess and young
genius lady may sound like a title
designed to give your brain an aneurysm
but it's a show that instantly charms
you into its world and characters it's
one of those shows that actually tries
to tell a classic fantasy story over
doing [__] isakai stuff and a lot of
this is down to the protagonist being an
absolute force of nature
[Music]
I'm convinced she's The Reincarnation of
chisato in a fantasy world because she
takes over any scene with her infectious
energy but I know I know there's a lot
of visca this season what is this show
doing that's more special than every
other easy guy airing right now
isn't it
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month too Alpha
Sigma author Curtis Eckstein basil
dysfunctional degenerate flabberwocky
ivido lovados
misaka12315 Payne patches Pony Stark
Water Guys VT and everyone else my
patreon for helping to support me for
this month and making this video
possible so sorry this winter video is a
bit late I put all my resources into
making the best of anime 2020 too and
once I'm finished with that I just found
how many new shows I had to end up
watching so I am really hoping this
trend of adding more new anime every
season kind of ends because this season
had a ridiculous number of shows I had a
hard time keeping up with anime before
so if every season this year has as many
shows as this season did it's gonna be
nylon impossible to keep up man shout
out to those people still trying to
watch as many shows as possible because
my plan to watch list on Mao is just
growing more and more every year and I
don't know if I can ever catch up but
that's it for me today I don't have many
updates to tell you guys so I'm just
gonna leave it at that I've been gigock
and I'll see you all next time